and we start at six o'clock with  breaking news sources confirming to our  eight news now i-team there are multiple  victims of a shooting in the northwest  part of the valley madison kim breaux is  live near the scene near 95 and 215 now  joining us with the very latest updated  information madison  heavy police activity in this  neighborhood take a look for yourself  we're near centennial and tropical as  you just saw the area is taped off metro  police confirming that this is a  homicide investigation while it's still  unclear sources tell the eight news now  i-team that two people are dead and  multiple people have been shot metro  will be doing a briefing coming up very  soon so keep it here on eight news now  for the latest details reporting live in  centennial hills madison kimbrough live  local now